hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the 37th European Club Cup
this is a game from round two and it is
a world champion Magnus Carlsen on his
quest to that 2900 rating against the
German Grandmaster Alexander uh now man
I will have to try very hard not to
pronounce it Neiman as that's what
everyone is talking about these days but
I will do my best and yes I'm still
working on the steinit Saga I'm very
close to uh finishing it uh to the point
where I will feel comfortable you know
of starting another Saga like I
mentioned in the previous video I will
start probably next week maybe even this
week but so far things are looking great
there's some incredible data that I have
recovered uh you know from various books
and weird sources so I think you guys
will enjoy it and now let's get to the
game uh it's a really nice one played in
the style of all the Masters uh so yeah
let's dive straight into the Magnus with
the white pieces opens with E4 we have
E5 Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now D5
4 Magnus goes for The Scorch game
something we haven't seen in quite a
while especially by the world champion e
Captain D4 Knight captures and now two
of the lines are uh well particularly uh
enjoyable here for black that is the
classical line with Bishop to C5 this is
the most analyzed line the one you know
where just bring the bishop to C5 you
put the queen on F6 you go for checkmate
uh and uh well this is something uh you
teach everyone you you go to a chess
club this is what they will teach you
but here we have Knight to F6 it's a
different one is the Schmidt variation
and it's also a very forcing line that
you have to of course know if you play
it as those two are fairly uh of the
same popularity the C5 line a bit more
popular so Knight captures and C6 B
captures a sorry B captures on C6 and
not Pawn to E5 eliminating the Knight
here so you can advance the pawn queen
to E7 now uh the the pawn cannot move as
the king is only one and queen T2 so
again nothing new here all been played
before Knight to D5 and here there are
two again very popular choices that
black and that white can play that is
the further harass the Knight with C4 or
the play H4 prepared Bishop to G5 and so
on but here Magnus plays Knight to D2
and he shows that he prepared something
very special for this game
so okay what can black do uh well there
are uh many moves you can try here there
are very few games that have reached
this position so it is very very
unexplored territory he goes for Knight
to F4 uh attacks Carlson's Queen here
Magnus plays a queen to E3 that's the E4
which is interesting E4 is the more
active square and now uh there are some
games where Knights the E6 were played
in night the G6 were played but here now
one just repeats Knight to D5 and he
attacks the White Queen once again and
it is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game sort of checking if
Magnus will go for a repetition of moves
that is very unlikely that he would
settle for a draw here he has uh over
300 rating points higher rated but uh
you know you you you play it to see if
the Black Wing has a better Square so
Queen to E4 and now okay there's a
different plan fonte F6 now if Pawn
captures uh now the Knight can recapture
on F6 so Magnus chases away the Knight
C4 and this is a very very ambitious try
and black will get a lot of play here
Knight to B4 now and it's very hard to
find the move for Magnus because uh well
what do you play here if you try to
chase away the Knight which seems like a
logical thing to do you do not want to
decide staring at the C2 square there's
D5 and now uh one of the one of the
ideas of bringing the queen to E4 was
that D5 can be played with Tempo and now
if C capture C captures look at this the
White Queen cannot remain on this
diagonal unless it goes all the way back
to B1 and if Bishop to B1 now Queen
captures an E5 with the check followed
by Bishop to F5 and that's pretty much
it so uh what did Magnus have in mind
allowing Knights to be for well Magnus
had in mind King to D1 uh playing real
chess in the style of Old Masters not
allowed not uh you know scared to use
the King as a weapon already as of move
12 which is uh you know uh very nice as
there are so many pieces on the board so
here Queen captures an E5 interesting uh
choice you could also play F characters
and E5 and keep the Queens on the board
which uh which suits some of the players
as the white king cannot Castle but uh
Alexander goes for the queen trade very
early on Magnus plays A3 and now Queen
captures an E4 Knight captures Knight
back to A6 and now Magnus of course
plays Pawn to B4 a move uh vital to any
chest position but here uh it serves as
means of keeping the knight at base so
the Knight cannot re-enter the game if
you wanna uh bring it back into the game
it's gonna have to go to B8 then
probably to D7 at some point or or
something so Alexander tries to activate
it right away he plays C5 and now okay
Magnus just plays B5 says that Knight is
not uh coming into the game anytime soon
Bishop to B7 first attacking the
undefended Knight here and now just Bush
up to D3 Knight does go to B8 uh and now
Magnus plays Rook to E1 threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries King to F7
and now Knight back to C3 offering yet
another Pawn but it would be a bit
dangerous to capture this Pawn if you
capture it right away then Bishop to F4
is very nasty just going after the C7
pawn and the only good way to defend it
is to play something like D6 but then
you get Bishop to F5 then Bishop to E6
check comes and it's very very hard to
play this with black with with Magnus
having the bishop pair control of the E
file denied being able to to jump to D5
looks very scary so okay Bishop to D6
first you will grab the pawn at some
point now but you've developed your
bishop and you prevented Magnus from
playing Bishop to F4 so Magnus plays F4
now offering another pawn and okay
Bishop captures on G2 the grabbing the
pawn is the best move Magnus plays King
to C2 and now King the uh and now Pawn
to G6 so you can develop The Rook the H7
Pawn will not be hanging and here Magnus
plays a staggering Bishop to B2 and now
Magnus is giving up another Pawn so he
already gave up two pawns and now he's
giving up a third Pawn now the Old
Masters sort of had a saying it's okay
to accept one Pawn it's uh you know
except uh the second Pawn maybe okay
that's that's very bold but accepting
that third Pawn you have to be
incredibly sure to accept the third pawn
and here it would be better to for
example play something like F5 and now
okay the pawn is still hanging but your
position has improved and if Knights the
D5 opening an attack on The Rook you can
play Rook E8 or for a rook trade and
let's say if the Rooks get traded off
now you give back one Pawn let's say
Knight F6 check Magnus picks up the H7
pawn and the game continues but uh this
seems like uh it's sort of maybe
uh uh Alexander had the idea that maybe
he was uh having something against
Magnuson he just didn't want to let him
off the ropes and he played Bishop
captures on F4 and now he grabbed the
third Pawn which means that if Magnus
does not have something spectacular then
black is just winning I mean you can't
play being down three pawns but what did
Magnus have in mind here he plays a rook
to E2 attacks the bishop here and now
okay the bishop has to move first you
can play Bishop F3 because then Rook F2
and one of the Bishops will hang so the
bishop has to go back Bishop back to B7
and now Magnus plays Rook to F1 so okay
he's down three pawns but he has two
monster Bishops here he has a knight
ready to jump to D5 he has full control
of the E file and for the moment very
very nice control of the f file and how
do you play this G5 is played defending
the bishop this is uh you know it's a
it's it doesn't look great but it is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
and Magnus just attacks the G5 pawn pawn
to H4 and now again it's a it's a hard
position for black you could try
defending with H6 but in the game D6 was
played and again it seems like uh now
you're gonna play Knight to D7 the
Knight comes into the game and you are
uh well very very happy with your
position but now Magnus just plays h
captress on G5 and now the problem is
you cannot capture back if you play
let's say Bishop captures and G1 now
Rook F to E1 and you are getting
destroyed here uh point is that because
C5 was played and the disappointed B5
move was allowed the Knight can never
get active I can't go to A6 can't go to
C6 can't go to D7 because now Rook The
Rook E7 check picks up the Knight so
black is basically playing without a
rook and Knight and this Rook still has
to somehow somehow get activated another
thing after each captures on G5 you
might consider F captures on G5 but then
look at this bishop E4 attacks the
bishop the bishop cannot move because
the real King so you have to trade
Bishop captures with track Knight
captures and again what do you play The
Rook is hanging the G5 Pawn is is
hanging because the bishop is spinned
one thing you could consider is
something like Rook to jit to keep
everything in check but just Knight
captures and G5 check Rook captures now
Rook captures an F4 check and look at
this the two Rooks and the bishop just
doing a spectacular job here uh what can
you play with King to G6 Rook to F6
checking to H5 Rook to H to check and
you know the the king hunt continues
King G4 Rook captures on H7 again not
allowing the knights to be activated
um this is just the incredibly sad
position for black there's just nothing
you can play you can never activate this
at this Knight and Rook so instead after
H Captain G5 Alexander tried Bishop to
E5 at least he will stop the bishop on
this diagonal but now Magnus just played
Knight to E4 now also possible and
perhaps a bit more precise is Knight to
the D5 simply because again it prevents
the knight from ever being activated
point is that after bishop captress and
King captures you can again never
activate the Knight because now Rook to
E7 check would win the night is then uh
the the Knight controls the E7 Square
after Knight the E4 it is possible to
activate the Knight but Magnus figured
that it doesn't really matter so here
Knights the D7 was played uh right away
if you go for Bishop captures here like
in the previous line then King captures
and after Knight to D7 you can just play
Knight captures on F6 and again white is
just breaking through so this might even
be the best attempt for black uh but
it's still and not all that much so
Knights the D7 was played and now Magnus
just goes for Knight captures on F6 with
check Knight captures and F6 and now the
incredible Bishop captures on E5 it's
very important to uh to play this first
because then all of the threats remain D
cap is an E5 Rook captures an E5 and it
was in this position on move 30 that
Alexander nowman resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the Knight will uh will fall next and
even though okay you might be equally
material for the moment that's not going
to last for long let's say you play Rook
H to E8 you don't even have to rush it
with real characters here you can even
play real captors and C5 just grab a
Pawn on threaten this Pawn so you can
win the bishop uh not all that much to
play rookie the C8 you then capture the
Knight with Rook captures and F6 check
King G7 and now even Bishop to F5
attacking The Rook here and now if the
Rook moves you're gonna win the C7 Pawn
with check uh so maybe bishop E4 check
force uh force a trade here but again
and it doesn't help white can just go
after the A7 pawn and now you you cannot
defend here uh rookie seven Rook
captures on A7 you have to keep both of
the Rooks here to guard the C7 Pawn but
then B6 is a threat uh I mean uh just
just A4 A5 A6 B5 and you just push the
pawns and um uh it's it's just game over
uh so yeah beautifully done by Magnus uh
Alexander also played incredibly well uh
but uh at that moment where where Magnus
decided to offer the F4 Pawn as well uh
sometimes you you can accept one Pawn
you can accept two pawns but it's very
very rare that you can actually accept
three pawns uh maybe you can if your
opponent is just wondering pawns but uh
chances are Magnus is not uh so yeah
very very nicely done and I very much
enjoyed this as I am preparing for the
steinit Saga so you know a game like
this uh you know just giving up pawns
for Rapid development is very very much
appreciated from from the world champion
in 2022. uh sure uh that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it do play the
scotch you know it offers many many
wonderful adventures uh to do whoever
tries it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Peter and I would like
to thank tosuli I love you uh Alan
Bradbury yeah as the Grand and storm 70
on bandcamp for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh the uh to check up on you
one of the suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World while I'm
preparing The steinit Saga so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day